believe it or not but I've owned every
single PlayStation since the very first
PlayStation 1 original
what's going on guys my name is David
homage and welcome back to the channel
today we're talking about the brand new
Playstation 5 which has been semi
released by Sony we've heard many many
rumors leading up to it but we've also
now been given a glimpse of what looks
like what it's capable of and what kind
of gains we'll be expecting
believe it or not but I have owned every
single PlayStation since the very first
PlayStation 1
I remember getting it a day after school
and my parents brought it home and I had
Spyro the Dragon and croc set up and it
was one of the best days of my life so
when the PS 5 came out it was something
to be excited about as a fully grown
adult
so what PlayStation has come out and
stated is that the official device will
be released towards the end of this year
anywhere between October and December
with a more likely modest price of 500
USD so if that's anything to go off
buying all the rumors of the pricing
which is 500 USD my stab in the dark
would be the simple fact that in
Australia it's gonna cost probably just
under $1,000 the last PlayStation that
came out was very very close to it on
launch and when we go back to the ps3 it
was 7-8 150 or 650 or something like
that off the top of my head it was very
expensive so going into the PS 5 that's
capable of doing absolutely everything
at a flagship premium level it's more
than likely gonna be priced right up
there to the thousand dollar mark so
let's start by talking about the actual
design of the PS 5 and it is definitely
something that is striking it is an all
white with a blue neon inside and it's
very futuristic when you first see it
and you see the two versions you start
thinking why is there two versions but
it makes sense very quickly when the two
logos appear we're gonna have the
digital version only and the one with
the disc drive so the one on the disc
drive will obviously allow you to
backdate or your ps4 disc games and use
any new PS flour games
whereas the digital
version I'm unsure how that's gonna
backdate and let you use any previous
games that you've used but there might
be able to integrate some sort of
software trans cross compatibility I
don't really know it'll be a very
interesting thing to see if people will
decide to go with the digital-only
version because they want to go digital
from here on in or if they're gonna
stick to the hardware version with the
CD drive in it because they want to be
able to play their old ps4 games while a
ton of new games get released slowly as
they always do on the PlayStation
Network personally I'm a huge fan of the
design I think it's very striking
beautiful white and sleek very
minimalistic and it somewhat reminds me
of architecture and debye if you've ever
been to buy if you've ever seen any
pictures you could easily slot this
towel right into the skyline and nobody
it would be none the wiser the one thing
that we haven't really been told by Sony
is what this device is going to cater
for yes we know it's a state-of-the-art
AMD chip with an 825 gigabyte SSD
custom-built hard drive in it now we
know also the fact that the hard drive
is custom-built for the specific fact
that it's got ray-tracing in it and it's
going to need a bump out that
information really really quickly in
order to be able to use this ray-tracing
features inside it but what we haven't
been told is are they gonna focus on the
gaming only experience or they going to
start focusing on the Sony network as a
whole when we think about Sony some of
us think about the PlayStation some of
us think about the cinema and the
cinematography that they do so Sony as a
franchise has done billions of dollars
worth of things over the years
so if Sony wanted to for example they
could begin competing with Netflix and
Disney Plus and all those other
streaming platforms and all of a sudden
bring up their own Sony platform or even
provide it free of charge to PlayStation
5 users why would this benefit somebody
well it's very simple actually if you
open up a new library to a whole new
customer base people who are buying
PlayStation phibes aren't just hardcore
gamers anymore
they're now families who want to watch
movies they're young couple
who don't want to pay for Netflix but
they also want a good 4k player and they
want playing games sometimes so all of a
sudden it isn't just that dedicated
market but it is almost everybody it
might be looking at the PS 5 and what it
could and can't do so I think as more
information gets released about the PS 5
and the more we learn about it it'll be
very interesting to see what direction
Sony goes into are they gonna be going
into yep we're a gaming focused it's
only gonna be about gaming and we're
going to focus on that 4k potentially 8k
cross compatibility in the future really
focusing heavily on the frame per second
going from what we're all very much used
to if 30 frames a second now and
hopefully bumping it up to 120 frames a
second as we're starting to see in
mobile devices laptops and all other
technology platforms now in 2020 so as
we move into 2021 very rapidly and as
the PS 5 comes out towards the end of
2020 these games hopefully in 2021 will
be coming out at 120 frames per second
this will become a very different
experience for the ps4 that we all got
so used to playing that 30 frames a
second if you've been able and lucky
enough to experience 120 frames a second
on any device be at the s20 beaded
laptop be at a desktop then you know
there is a huge difference playing fast
paced games at 120 frames a second
something like call of duty then that is
something that will really revolutionize
the gaming experience now if you end up
pairing the PS 5 with the Philips hue
lighting that I talked about in one of
my last videos you can all of a sudden
transform your entire room into this
gaming epicenter you could have the
lights changing and be really immersed
into this technology and into the PS 5
experience anyway that's all we really
know about PS 5 so far guys it is a
limited amount of information but it is
revealed we know what it's going to look
like we know the 20 odd games they're
going to come out with the release we
know the accessories and we pretty much
know what we're in for from the launch
the only thing we don't know is the
software and the price what's it going
to be running how's it going to
games how's the doodle a diversion gonna
be cross-compatible backwards-compatible
we don't know but hopefully we'll find
out very very soon as PlayStation
continues to release information if you
enjoyed the video make sure you smash
that subscribe button
20:20 style and as always I'll see you
next Monday